and then you think of the cowboy  vegas pick who's building 51 designed by  it came the design came from somewhere  else but ben did all the technical  drawings we still have the original  vellum that he did  and his arms functionally moved for 50  years  for 24 hours a day and you know we've  often wondered  do you have a moving piece of equipment  in your home or your business that's  been moving for 50 years it's still  working today i mean our cars don't last  that long  you know they're more complicated but  you know we kept the cowboy going all  those years  and so that's a you know phenomenal  thing eventually he developed a little  shimmy in his shimmy  so and the counter the counterbalance  has started to kind of hit the structure  so we realized we had to with a little  bit of age we had to shut him down  the moving arms that is but he's still  you know alive and well and in great  shape underneath that beautiful canopy  fremont street